Rosie O'Donnell has become a voice of
reason on the gender Madness
tell me that her stuffed animals were
non-binary
I'm like here we go
here we go and I said okay well what
does that mean she goes they don't feel
like a boy and they don't feel like a
girl I said well that's fantastic do you
know what's funny is that I'm a girl who
people used to call a tomboy because I
liked all the boy stuff when I was
little and you know what's weird I still
do really like the boy stuff I like
football I like riding a motorcycle I
like to do a lot of stuff that boys
traditionally like to do but you know
what else never was confused about
thinking if I was a boy or a girl always
knew I was a girl and loved being a girl
so you can be a girl and feel any way
you want or you can figure out what it
what it is and I'm like rambling and
rambling and she said are you done are
you done
this was Rosie O'Donnell's daughter was
saying I don't know if I feel like a
girl or a boy and Rosie making this
point saying you can be a girl and still
like the boy stuff
of course had Rosie O'Donnell been a
child today
depending on her parents and her
community they almost certainly would
have tried to trans her but she says no
I'm not a boy I'm a girl
I'm a girl who has a sexual desire for
other girls I'm a girl who likes to ride
motorcycles I'm a girl who likes to
watch football but I'm a girl because
you can't change that
and even the people who think that you
can change that that if if you're a girl
but you like football you're a boy and
you need to chop your body up they know
that they're not identical with boys
even the really pro-trans people they
know that there's a difference they know
that they're in some ways at least
they're like the sex that they appear to
be and are
so Rosie's just giving a different
perspective here
and
Rosie is more right than most people on
this issue it's not even quite so simple
as Rosie is making it though
there's some people who are saying
being a girl is purely about biology
X chromosomes in a uterus and then there
are other people who are saying being a
girl has nothing to do with Biology it
has to do with whether you have pretty
dresses and Barbie dolls
and there are the first group of people
they'll say no actually it has nothing
to do with whether you like Barbie doll
you can not like Barbie dolls you can
wear blue jeans
and neither side is totally right
I I was at the TP USA Pastors conference
yesterday I'm not a I am not a pastor
but I was speaking to a group of of
pastors there and a young woman came up
to me
and she said Michael
what is a woman
we never seem to get an answer to that
it's a it's a great question and the
Liberals can't answer it but we we don't
really seem to get a precise answer on
the right either sometimes people will
say oh it's a an adult female okay sure
but
what does that mean and sometimes people
say X chromosomes but okay what does
that mean sometimes people will say the
Barbie dolls and the dress is in so what
is it
and one answer that I like to give is
that a woman is sugar spice and
everything nice I think that's much more
precise than any of the other answers
that people give
being a girl
is is about a lot of different things
and where Rosie goes a little bit wrong
actually she says you can like whatever
you want and do whatever you want still
be a girl well yeah maybe but actually
if you're a girl you are called to do
certain things
you actually do have certain
a certain kind of purpose you actually
do have certain behaviors that are
implied by your biology by yourself
and I know that's not popular to say
these days but it's true and if you're a
man you have certain obligations and
duties too and you can act like a man
a woman is not
just her body a woman is at least her
body but she's not just her body there's
more to being a woman than that so
Rosie's on the right track but there's
more to say right now go to
goodranchers.com use promo code Knowles
Memorial Day is a time to honor and
remember our brave servicemen and women
who made the ultimate sacrifice for our
country it is also a time to come
together as a nation gather with loved
ones and enjoy some mouth-watering meals
what better way to do that than with
premium 100 American meat from good
ranchers good ranchers is not like the
other meat delivery companies that
import a majority of their products they
are passionate about delivering the
finest 100 American meat right to your
doorstep
here's something special good ranchers
proudly offers a 10 discount to all past
and present service members as a way of
saying thank you for their service but
that's not it
in honor of Memorial Day good ranchers
is giving our listeners an exclusive
opportunity when you use code Knowles
kwles you can save 20 off site-wide from
tender steaks to succulent chicken
goodranchors.com has it all I had the
other night a juicy delicious good
ranchers burger and it's
it's the best
it's the best burger out there and the
steaks are just Juicy and Delicious and
it's just top shelf meat okay fire up
the grill on Memorial Day and your
family and friends will thank you for it
they will know that the meat that
everyone is enjoying is not only of the
highest quality but also supports
American ranchers goodranches.com head
on over use code Knolls save 20
site-wide the more you stock up on the
more you will save during the Memorial
Day sale promo code knows at
goodranchers.com good ranchers American
Meat delivered green Jean-Pierre White
House Press actually was asked a
question about the sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence which is this rabidly
anti-christian particularly
anti-catholic drag queen Troop that is
being honored by the LA Dodgers more
like L gay Dodgers if you ask me
tip your waitress she was asked this
question because the president is at
least nominally Catholic here's her
answer
this is one that's really caught the eye
of a lot of Catholics and Christians and
it's in frankly they're they're hurt by
this the the LA Dodgers are honoring a
group called The Sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence during a pride night game
next spot the Archdiocese of La Catholic
leaders there say the group mocks the
Catholic faith and women religious who
serve the poor and sick and is asking
all Catholics to stand against bigotry
and hate in any form
the president is Catholic we all know
what is his reaction look I appreciate
the question Owen I'm just not going to
get into the middle of uh of uh who a
sports team is going to uh honor or
should honor or should not honor that's
just not something that I'm going to get
in the middle of it has made it uh you
know it's very important in religious
freedom he's issued statements on it in
the past saying all people of all
religions should be treated with equal
dignity and respect I know I know you
you know we just said you just said
there you kind of want to stay out of it
but this isn't this a prime example of
something like that I'm just not going
to get in the middle of who a sports
team decides to honor or not honor that
is not just not going to get in the
middle of that but appreciate the
question oh yeah I'm not going to get in
the middle of that we listen we
from political office we're not going to
get involved with what sports teams are
doing right as if the entire Democratic
party didn't weigh in on the NFL
kneeling
white supremacy Fiasco of
2016-2017. as if Joe Biden could he ever
keep his mouth shut on any of these
cultural issues as if the White House
didn't invite Dylan Mulvaney
to come do an interview with him give me
a break what are you talking about
White House is always involved in these
things he just doesn't want to comment
on this because it's indefensible and
yet he knows that his side is on the
side of the anti-christian
drag queens
and so he he doesn't want to put himself
in a bad position where he's going to
have to overtly and publicly disavow his
faith in order to decide with them
but he also doesn't want to defend the
faith
because he knows where his bread is
buttered at least in this world it's
it's with the anti-christians
so so they keep their mouths shut okay
it is increasingly clear that we are
facing an assault on Christianity and on
all traditional views of society and
morality and religion even for people
who don't consider themselves Christian
you probably cherish a lot of the fruits
of Christian civilization and now all of
that is under assault
so when you ask me which candidate do I
want to back in 2024 is it Trump is it
DeSantis is it Chris Christie don't
count Chris Christian is it Vivek
ramaswamy is it Nikki is it this is it
I
want to back the candidate
that can see the assault on religion
that is going on right now the sacrilege
that is going on right now that will not
merely
chip away at popular piety but will
fundamentally undermine all of the most
important aspects of our society
because religion is not just some fun
little hobby that people have in society
or they don't religion is what animates
the whole society and so if you live in
a culture that publicly mocks religion
then you're you're not going to have a
very flourishing Society so which
candidate am I going to go for I'd like
the candidate who can credibly
propose to stop that all-out assault the
ridiculous line from the White House oh
it's just some little sports team thing
right Sports is public this is the team
of the city the LA Dodgers public Sports
have always had a patriotic component
they tell us a lot about what our
culture believes what our political
order is going to be of course we've got
to be involved If Sports weren't
political the LA Dodgers wouldn't be
honoring a sacrilegious drag Troop of
course it's political and you're going
to keep your mouth shut because the
politics is going in your direction and
you don't want to upset that I want a
Republican presidential candidate who's
willing to upset that boy what a clip if
you want more of that if you want long
interviews if you want the yes or no
game if you want The Daily Show you got
to check out the Michael Knowles YouTube
channel and ring that Bell And subscribe
we'll see you next time